Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show. I am Jesse Dallimore, filling in for my
final day for David while he is away. Well, they
did it. House Republicans with their new majority,
voted Ilhan Omar off the Foreign Affairs Committee
gleefully. They did it. They did it while. Putting
Marjorie Taylor GREENE back on committees.
They did it while Lauren Boebert holds a spot
on the House Oversight and Accountability
Committee. They did it while Paul Gosar,
an avowed white nationalist, also has committee
assignments. And Democrats showed up in force to
support Congresswoman Ilhan Omar. I'm going to
play three clips for you. One is Eric Swalwell.
Genius points. One is AOC, who talks about the
rampant in rank hypocrisy of Republicans who act
like they're in it to to curb anti-Semitism, which
is nonsense, because Kevin McCarthy just tweeted
this a few months ago. We cannot allow Soros and
Styer and Bloomberg to buy this election. Get out
and vote Republican in November 6th. Maga with a a
grainy picture of the Jewish George Soros. Soros.
So it is not in good faith or believable
or reputable in any way, shape or form
that this is about combating anti-Semitism
in the Congress. So if that were the case,
Paul Gosar would not have a job. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE would not have a job. And I
dare say Kevin McCarthy would not have a job.
Here's Eric Swalwell making some salient points.
Speaker 2: Gentleman is recognized for one minute.
Speaker 3: Madam Speaker, when I heard that we're
going to remove a member of this House from
their committee for anti-Semitism, I raced down
here because I thought finally, finally in this
chamber, there's going to be some accountability,
some accountability from this conference that
continues to allow its members to root for
rioters, to show sympathy for the insurrection,
a conference that harbors a wanted international
criminal and has members who choose violence over
voting every single day finally. And so I thought,
we're going to hold someone accountable for
anti-Semitism. Surely it's the author of this
tweet, Kanye, Elan, Trump, October
six, written by Chairman Jim Jordan,
October eight. What is Conyers say? I'm going to
declare Def Con three on the Jews. So surely this
tweet came down right. Came down, was deleted. No.
Two more months. It was kept up. Two more months.
So don't come here looking at us for
antisemitism. Look in your own damn mirror
before you ever come over here and I yield back.
Speaker 1: Where is he Wrong. How is he wrong?
Jim Jordan has his little special burner account
that happens to be the House Republican
Judiciary Committee Twitter account.
Conner, Ellen Trump Whether trolling or
not, they're promoting a vile anti-Semite.
AOC equally fired up someone who has been
threatened by anti-Semites in the House not
because of religion. But these vile actors,
these bad actors within the Republican Party,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Paul Gosar, who
depicted her death, are still on highly
sought after committees. What AOC.
Speaker 2: All right, gentlemen,
is recognized for one minute.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Now, I as
also as a fellow New Yorker, I think one of
the things that we should talk about here
is also one of the disgusting legacies after
911 has been the targeting and racism against
Muslim Americans throughout the United States of
America. And this is an extension of that legacy
consistency. There is nothing consistent with
the Republican Party's continued attack except
for the racism and incitement of violence against
women of color in this body. I had a member of the
Republican caucus threaten my life and you all
and the Republican caucus rewarded him with one
of the most prestigious committee assignments
in this Congress. Don't tell me this is about
consistency. Don't tell me that this is about
an ad, a condemnation of anti-Semitic remarks.
When you have a member of the Republican caucus
who has talked about Jewish space lasers and an
unintended amount of tropes and also elevated her
to some of the highest committee assignments in
this body. This is about targeting women
of color in the United States of America.
Don't tell me because I didn't get a single
time in the spotlight. Like to threaten.
Thank you.
Speaker 1:
And crickets from Republicans pushing forward
to vote her off committees. And this is this is
racism. This is fear of other. This is anti-black
is what? This is anti-immigrant, anti-woman.
As Ilhan Omar herself will explain. She got the
last word in this before the vote. I guess you got
the second to last word since Republicans did get
the last word. I talked about this the other day,
that it was a foregone conclusion that this was
going to happen and now it has. But before it did,
Ilhan Omar did get to speak.
Speaker 2: This debate today,
it's about who gets to be an American.
What opinions do we get to have? Do we
have to have to be counted as Americans? This
is what this debate is about, Madam Speaker.
There is this idea that you are a suspect if you
are an immigrant or if you are from certain parts
of the world or a certain skin tone or a muslim.
It is no accident that members of the Republican
Party accused the first black president,
Barack Obama, of being a secret Muslim.
It is no accident that former President Donald
Trump led a birther movement that falsely claimed
he was born in Kenya. Because to them falsely
labeling the first and only president of the
United States of America, a muslim, an African
immigrant, somehow made him less American.
Well, I am Muslim. I am an immigrant.
And interestingly, from Africa.
Is anyone surprised that I am being targeted? Is
anyone surprised that I am somehow deemed unworthy
to speak about American foreign policy or that
they see me as a powerful voice that needs to
be silenced? Frankly, it is expected because when
you push power, power pushes back. Representation
matters. Continuing to expand Our ideas of who
is American and who can partake in the American
experience experiment is a good thing. I am
an American. An American who was sent here,
an American who was sent here by her constituents
to represent them in Congress. A refugee who
survived the horrors of a civil war. Someone
who spent her childhood in a refugee camp.
Speaker 1: None of that matters to Republicans.
Republicans who prattle on about the American
dream and quote Reagan about being a shining city
on a hill. And yet they punish and ostracize and
oppress a member of their own body. Because she's
black, she's Muslim, and she's a former refugee.
Who became a citizen, who and who should
to them embody the American dream.
If they weren't vile,
pernicious hypocrites, that is.